mr. white [ __ ]
hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey we are gonna talk about El
Camino a Breaking Bad movie it's planned
in select theaters right now it's
available on Netflix before we go into
this I wanted to say thank you to
everyone who has downloaded and followed
us on the Stardust app over there would
you 30-second reactions and reviews for
many films many shows and many trailers
a lot of what we actually don't cover on
YouTube we post weekly sometimes it's
pretty much daily you can post - the
whole thing is completely free to
download and use use our special link in
the description box get it today
peebo now let's talk about El Camino a
Breaking Bad movie so what we're gonna
do is keep a non spoiler and then if
we're feeling like it we might talk
about some spoilers at the end of this
video because there are some definite
things you can spoil here that are
pretty exciting stuff and needless to
say Breaking Bad serious spoilers if
you're here already
you haven't seen Breaking Bad you're
gonna get some stuff spoiled this movie
is highly meant for people who have seen
Breaking Bad it's not one of those
movies that takes place after the show
but it's like even if you haven't seen
the show it's a reintroduction there's
none of that if you haven't seen the
show you will just easily be confused
you won't get a lot of the nuances and
that's one of the cool things I actually
like about the movie is that it is in no
way shape or form meant to hold anyone's
hand through the breaking bam yeah yeah
and watch that recap but even still not
gonna I was like wait I don't remember
that yeah yeah yeah it takes place
instantly after the events of Jesse's
final moment in Breaking Bad getting
away after being tortured by those you
know white supremacist kind of
characters yeah just being a meth slave
yes
Walt is now dead this is Vince
Gilligan's version of a fugitive on the
run kind of tail I love the movie it's
different than Breaking Bad it's
different than better call Saul but it
feels like a natural part of the
universe completely yeah I think the
word that's been thrown around a lot is
the word epilogue and that's the perfect
way to great it doesn't feel like an
extended episode to me if anything it
feels like a movie but there are times
where it might feel like the best
special episode you've ever seen
and one of the two it's gonna fluctuate
between and this was a fascinating
prospect because you know we don't do
this all the time but we do live in a
time where shows get revitalized in
different ways and especially with a
show that had as good a track record and
ended as well as Breaking Bad did I was
like how are we gonna make a movie out
of this and what really works so well
and what struck me during the experience
was it's great because the show is
Walt's story and Walt's story goes to
its completion and it really makes sense
to give Jesse's and his true ending to
his story aside you know a piece like
this and I thought it was clever because
Jesse gets these glasses called Edith oh
yeah I was on this skeptical spectrum at
first too when the movie was announced
but when revisiting or at least you know
because I've seen the show twice it's my
favorite drama of all time in terms of
television and it's true like Jesse's
ending one way was open-ended and then
another way was when I got a lot of
questions now though he's a future Dave
he's really traumatized yeah it's his
girlfriend the love of his life was
murdered what's happening to Brock
how does he just get away yeah and I
think for the ending of Breaking Bad
that magic really works that ambiguity
of like this is well it's one final good
thing that he held to do but yeah at the
same time you're like he's still got a
hell of a lot to go through before his
life has any kind of continuation to it
and speaking of continuation I thought
it was great of how they kept Jesse's
character instantly like strongly
affected cuz it's so quick after the
ending of Breaking Bad cuz I think when
we think of Jesse usually we think of
like loud angry like a kid and here he's
a traumatized man this movie is quiet I
feel like a good word for it could be
meditative in a lot of ways but it's
also still really intense it does a good
job at closing this chapter but then
also you know some I don't know if the
right words filling in the gaps because
it has these flashbacks Dean sends a
little light into some key aspects of
his story as the complete protag yeah
yeah that and I don't really want to
detail it right now those are times
where it feels like was this a scene
that maybe Vince Gilligan had in mind
that he wanted to incorporate into the
show so that's when I could feel like a
cool special episode but still as a
complete package it's a well executed
moving Aaron Paul is incredible in this
movie with the idea that they shot these
extra flashbacks you see different
stages of Jesse in his life one thing
that I've always loved about Breaking
Bad specifically is that I've seen the
whole show twice when I Sri started it I
was like oh wow these characters are a
thousand percent different than they
were at the beginning of the show they
truly evolved Aaron Paul's ability to
hop in time between these different
portions yeah of the different stages of
Jesse's life feels so flawless and
authentic but even the monitored a touch
he's so cool in this movie more the
silent type jesse in here it's very
effective once I got used to the motif
of the then and now aspect of Jesse's
journey I thought it worked really
nicely because that's another area to
get kind of concerned about it's like oh
we're gonna go back and do some Breaking
Bad fan service yeah
and there are definite things in there
that people are gonna be bad [ __ ] but I
thought for the most part yeah they tied
everything into his immediate journey of
the plot took that time to comment on
the character then as opposed to the
character now and to really show you
that growth at least for me like I
definitely want to go back and see what
some of the finer nuances are cuz it is
really meditative and there are scenes
that are very quiet but it felt like it
all made sense to this journey because
it's not just a physical journey which
it is a very physical journey but it's
you know jesse is like strut like he's I
think as hard as possible just to get
out of this with the life he has left
you know and there's so many moments
where it could all end you know so you
feel the desperation he's still grieving
a lot like the man he's got PTSD he's
got PTSD there's a lot of the the
thematic choices of this I feel really
deal with the consequences of past
choice having to own up to your past
accepting your past that's why I think
the flashbacks I thought were essential
sometimes they were essential in getting
you to understand a certain plot point
and other times really helping you just
understand where Jesse's Adam what he is
truly overcoming what his complete arc
is gonna be by the end I want to talk
into a little bit about the writing and
directing of this because it's that's
the thing that strongly makes it
different from Breaking Bad especially I
kind of view this as a mix of like an
Unforgiven kind of western meets a
Hitchcock film
yeah cuz the way but it's really
fugitive because of the on the run with
this is done the way vince gilligan
would do this tale oh yeah it's it takes
its time it's a bit of a slow burner I
love the way he handles so much of the
the writing and directing in terms of
how he handles his reveals yeah
sometimes just within a long take of a
shot you don't know exactly what this
character is doing and then the camera
might pan down or reveal later oh that's
what lives you catch on to why a shot is
framed a certain yeah yeah yeah yeah he
does that a lot throughout the writing
it's the thing where it's not a big
mystery thriller but yet there's
something about it where there's a bit
of a mystery approach in the way this is
captured yeah yeah yeah and the
direction is I thought really expressive
there's a certain magic about Vince
Gilligan's writing and I mean that in
terms of like you know even when I'm
watching Breaking Bad for how gritty and
for how real it is there is a certain
kind of undefinable element of mysticism
to the world that I can't cope there's
just a certain a certain magic that
enchants the world and yeah I feel like
he has a really sharp eye for direction
for enhancing that because I think that
magic can break the illusion if it's not
directed quite so well but his choice of
really expressive wide shots really
expressive long takes and things like
that are really wonderful like spaces
and angles angles are like what a crazy
shot yeah exam the show yeah it really
does feel like this fascinating little
unique neo-noir western things I know
because like the music compose for this
the word that comes to mind is pulsating
every bit of music in here is constantly
reminding you of the chase the ticking
clock he has to get out and laying low
but it's kind of low-key cuz everything
is tense and quiet right right one thing
I do want to mention too is the friends
badger and skinny Pete they're teasing
the trailer skinny Pete in this movie
this might be my favorite moment of skin
he easily has is like the best thing
I've ever seen skinny pea do there's a
moment here really that's like the
greatest thing skinny Pete is a be done
yes just rose to the occasion this is
the best moment it and all the Breaking
Bad history just went up a notch in my
yeah now you're on notch once he's been
going around the news so it hasn't
and maybe if you like IMDB or something
a Robert Forrester has passed that's the
way the day this came out I found out
during the movie when he showed up I
found out right after because I wanted
to like look up some stuff and Robert
Forrester is great in the mall he's
perfect it's significant he's got some
of the best scenes with Jesse Pinkman in
the movie I'm not just saying that
because the guy passed away like they
know he's moments are so using great -
yeah and I thought he was in the show
yeah exactly like there were so many
wonderful little bits of memory that
would come back as scenes would unfold
because yeah I didn't have time really
to go back and revisit the show very
much and so his performance is really
wonderful and really expressive and yeah
he is one of the most significant I
think parts of the movie even if he is
not one of the most prevalent on screen
but this was a really great way to kind
of celebrate him I mean to put it in
closing the non spoiler part I do highly
recommend this movie it different kind
of character study journey of Jesse
Pinkman think of every cliche approach
this movie could have done any sequence
in this movie or what flashbacks they
chose to see to enhance the character
and it's all done differently yeah then
you would ever expect I was really
impressed with the film and I love the
way Jesse arcs in this movie if you are
a fan of Breaking Bad you know some
people say this film is not necessary
it's not necessary for the Walter White
journey it's not necessary even complete
the Breaking Bad journey but if you did
feel but if you like heard about Jesse
if ya if you did feel like there was
something that wasn't properly concluded
with Jesse like a lot of fans did if you
were just as invested as Jesse as Walter
yeah then I would highly recommend this
movie it stands on its own for in terms
of being Jesse's film I hope this gets
at least some Golden Globe nominations
yeah yeah yeah I think this is a
wonderful coda for the series I think
Aaron Paul does a terrific job yeah this
weirdly was like you know it's wrapped
up and and yeah you don't have to
because the show is from Walt's point of
view but yeah if if we're going to and
if you like spending time in this world
and if you like what Vince Gilligan's
style of writing and direction has to
offer you I thought this nailed it I
thought this as a Breaking Bad fan and
as somebody who was invested in both
Walt and Jesse pretty emotionally
throughout that journey I've walked away
with a lot of feelings from this so I
really appreciate it yeah now let's get
into some spoiler stuff here just
kills wall-to-wall wakes up he calls him
a [ __ ] for time he shoots him in the
face I did have a thought when I was
watching the movie was cuz you see it
starts off with a flashback of Mike
Jonathan banks a lot of the movie does
these flashbacks that make you go man
what if he had just made this decision
instead okay ending with Krysten Ritter
the Jonathan banks moment or even well I
want to go into is the Walter White mom
yeah because I had a thought of if they
have Walter White flashback in here it
better be late in the movie my exact
thought it better be to the point where
I'm not even thinking about yeah yeah so
when he showed up it wasn't thinking
about I was like I had to take a second
ago oh yeah this movie relies so much on
you knowing the show that yeah it takes
a moment to go okay which girlfriend was
he talking to on the phone in the hotel
Jesse it was that Jane if I'm not
mistaken is it right before a little bit
before they meet Gus because they're
trying to get 1 million dollars out of
like a giant batch they made yes they
want to sell the whole thing right first
off that was a defining moment to go
look how much air impulse exchanged yeah
from that guy to the man he is now right
leaning on pineapple yeah it's so so
different it was an interesting choice
because when you imagine dealing with
trauma or or what we know of Heisenberg
the character I was surprised by the how
they chose a quiet moment a subtle
conversational moment and a character
moment yeah that ultimately goes to
serve Jesse and I thought that was great
I loved that Brian Cranston was game to
do this the moment he got to have
because it's not the most flattering
Walt moment you know it's not about Walt
exactly and nor is it a wink at the
camera moment structurally it fit
perfect it wasn't just we got to do it
this makes actual perfect sense to have
this flash right same goes for everyone
I thought they might have shoehorn of
Saul Goodman moment in here but they
didn't and I'm glad they did it because
I had no point I mean they mentioned
your lawyer but that's about as far as
it goes but really I think the big thing
that I hope people really take notice of
is Jesse Plemons is taught
that that guy's a terrific terrific
actor and yeah this is such a strange
character and I I heard that there was
fat shaming going around towards Jesse
Plemons on the internet no that's mean
and don't do that don't attack an actor
cause of that admittedly though there is
that flipside where I was like oh
Todd is heavier than you when you see
the recap yeah but I'm not surprised
because I've seen Jesse Plemons in so
many movies to the point where that's
what he looks like it was when I was
watching from watching the recap of this
that's why but it's been so long since a
film bit that as an actor point of view
I'm like I didn't really even care what
actors weights fluctuate and I don't
know what he's doing like at the moment
and what his schedules like so maybe I
just couldn't slim down to do this movie
or something you know but yeah great the
scenes they chose to show of it's a
psychological torture we cut back and
forth in the last season of Breaking Bad
it's quick you feel the effect to live
in the torture in a in a way that's not
like hey they're just sitting him down
and punching him you know like look at
things they assign this awful life they
have this guy yeah yeah it's it's a lot
harsher than just we're going to beat
you up all the time yeah yeah and and
that's what makes the Todd stuff so
heartbreaking because it's almost worse
that he's trying to be nice in his own
twisted way because it's just that much
more terrible it's like it's like a pet
he can talk to yeah but and it really
highlights the disconnect between Todd
and humanity because something Kirby and
I mean the whole thing with the maid and
everything too good just goes to further
illustrate yeah what's he do you know
he's just so casual yeah maybe we can
paint but first we got to move my dad
made that moment where jesse has the
good cuz that was a moment where I'm
like oh I go in the glove compartment
gonna find right but the way that that
was executed was heartbreaking when he
when he has to make a choice as he knows
Brock's life is on the line you know
like just accept his pizza offered or
can I just kill this guy finally and you
just have that tear drop from his eye
when he's like saying pepperoni and and
that goes to show again it's like what
these highlights help with and what
Breaking Bad is always highlighted with
Walt and Jesse is the point of no return
is constantly reestablish yeah
and yeah I think one thing this also
highlights is how much Jessie has
learned to think cuz I think a younger
less-experienced Jessie might have just
capped him and drove off yeah this is
the most clever yeah movie overall is
clever and that's a heartbreaking moment
of watching him go okay I gotta think
this through and this is probably not
worth it as terrible as that seems you
know and that's a good way to put it
because with this movie being quieter it
is more of a thinking role than it is
and now you're finally watching you have
to think yeah constantly plot it out and
then in terms of like the arc with
Jessie being able to have that
conversation with his parents I love the
whole the whole way that went down with
finding the money in the fridge and the
fake cops coming in there good letting
the audience in on like these guys are
probably not real cops I thought was
smart but then when you get to the
moment with the showdown with the the
gunslinger sequence that was cool
because that was Jessie like really
arcing into a fighter at that gentleman
you know like because there's a couple
of sequences that he has here where he's
trying to escape he's trying to hide his
trying to run but then he ultimately is
forced a lot of the time to back it down
forcibly the long drama comes in yeah
and in that moment to shoot them it was
I thought that was a moment that was
earned of a true badass okay you know
cuz that's the moment where he's like
this is the last it's either Irie hit
the reset or I die trying and this is
the last $1,800 I need to die try yeah
it's not like Jessie on he's like cool
calm and collected about it yeah he's
just determined at that yeah this is
pure determination and the way it goes
down is great I've just like the amount
of gunshots he has to do it even again
the other guy where we finally shoots a
minute it's done in the most realistic
Western kind of completion yeah terrific
shot and the ending shot - I love how
mirrors here and parallels the finale of
breaking boy another was like yeah he's
he's finally he has a gentle smile that
crosses his face and they finally let
this go and the shift in the scenery I
think is a beautiful motif - from all
these desolate desert you know New
Mexico type lands yes to the snow to the
trees to the hills yeah I mean when the
movie started with Mike I felt like
Vince Gilligan was okay with letting you
in on he's probably gonna make it to
Alaska you know like the movie starts
off with Tahoe l asked I think I'd be
pretty bleak - yeah
yeah yeah and that's kind of a different
approach to that I thought would this
was like you kind of expect what Walter
White he's probably gonna die or get
captured by the end of the show like
when the show starts and then with this
one you're going I hope he gets a happy
ending yeah because you're watching
somebody who started this so young and
who now your rules be used and
manipulated the whole time and you've
been through so much that we just want
to see you just take control and live
your own life for once instead of living
the life that so like that's the thing
too and that flashback with Walt worries
like lecturing about going to college
yeah even guiding his focus to like you
should major in business actually yeah
and it shows you like how much influence
and how much manipulation so many of
these characters have put him through
yeah and it is so rewarding
I think Breaking Bad is interesting
because there are shocking and bleak
things that happen but there are rays of
hope and there are those little rays of
magic that enchant the periphery and I
think this kind of exemplifies that side
of it all right guys El Camino Breaking
Bad movie did you like it did you think
it was necessary did you think it was
well worth it would you want to see the
sequel guys you can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell make sure to download it falls on
the Stardust app thank you guys so much
for being here catch you guys soon